[Music]
Yogesh
in the past here against Denver is done
it in a close game again
off-balance leaning for the first time
all-star yogic with the king winner
three seconds to go
the pressure
you talk about
great defense there by Kelly who's a
junior there's nothing more you could do
defend across the switch vote against
tarnished
he knows my dad Larry Nance Jr the
Cavalier hero 92-91
believe me Fred it was deserving because
the man has played a great great game
he's done he's done pretty much
everything the night for the Cavaliers
and for him to get an opportunity that
is apropos for the catalyst is deserving
a great night finance and a great finish
[Applause]
buddy hield oh boy
vacations come to town and they steal
the game they steal the game stuns the
crowd here in Detroit back them up and
send them home Grande fear the
Sacramento Kings have shocked the
Detroit Pistons Buddy hield looking
looking pulled out of its three seconds
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
five seconds summers bringing in five
seconds ago tie game seatbelts are
fastened Luke Williams for the win
my goodness that just happened
Lou Williams can't mention that Ralph
you cannot measure what he has runner
looks lays it in to Trey two seconds
watch race fluttered
with love
[Applause]
what a play by Trey young the Florida
that he has perspectives and get all the
love on the sideline no man he's put
together a heck of a game
[Applause]
there's a
[Applause]
Costa can't defeat the Sussex walk 25
on the last second shot by the one time
sulphate Raja croco that's the way to
come home that's the way to remind
people what sue did for I can see blue
dolla five seconds left
waiters back to twin shoots now I
couldn't get it off that fires it up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just happened totally off its off the
glass circus shot and laid the hero once
again in his final game against the
Golden State Warriors Dwyane Wade beats
the worries
[Applause]
Toronto dude golly Miss Molly he did it
this crowd is done
a desperation free from lamb 3/4 court
Jeremy Lamb the shout of a lifetime the
Charlotte Hornets somehow on a Sunday
night experience the rapture here in
Toronto
what up and - boy Adam left coach you
like that content I know you like that
content hit subscribe for more of it
from Bleacher Report